the only thing you have in a complex
situation is the truth that's all you
have that's why you have to abide by the
truth you know because when things get
complex around you how do I deal with
this politically how do I deal with this
personally what do I say in this
terribly complex situation all you have
there that's Solid Ground is the truth
that's also why you have to live
honestly it's very hard to tell the
truth if you're simultaneously worried
that the evidence of your past deceitful
misbehavior is going to come to light
and so the reason you abide by the truth
is so that you can say what you have to
say about what you've done and who you
are and you can do that under impossibly
difficult circumstances and possibly
that will sustain you through that